[Music]
[Applause]
bring in our good buddy Ross Tucker
Westwood One CBS Sports and a former NFL
lineman host of the Ross Tucker football
podcast and Ross took a beating on
Twitter for your pregame Super Bowl
spread
pickled Pizza what the hell was going on
at the Ross Tucker compound
hahaha you know what Dan uh I this was
amazing actually I got a late text
message like mid-morning on Sunday from
a buddy that said he was having a
low-key Super Bowl party and the key is
it started at 5 30. I made it very clear
to him I would not be watching the game
with other people he was okay with that
so we took two separate cars I was in
one my wife and daughters and the other
they had an unbelievable spread they had
mozzarella stick Pizza which I had one
which was actually it was pepperoni and
mozzarella sticks but the the specific
Pizza you're referring to is called Big
Mac Pizza I guess his wife Patty likes
Big Macs that looked disgusting and I
did not partake at all I actually out of
everything they had I had like four
pieces of Stromboli I feel like as a
society as a country we don't talk
enough in a pre we talk about pizzas
pizza pizza I'm telling you right now
you put a pizza to the right Stromboli
to the left I am going Stromboli
Stromboli's amazing
well thanks for calling in that's all I
wanted to talk to you about
remember this super bowl for what in
particular
oh great question
um I think it depends a little bit on
what happens moving forward but a couple
things that jump out to me for sure you
know you know I do the Eagles preseason
games and I do their pre-game show I
think Jalen hurts coming of age you know
I mean if they're the one silver lining
for very disappointed Eagles fans right
now is that there was always kind of
that question Dan like can hurts really
do it like can he really do it in a big
playoff game against Josh Allen or job
or Mahomes then he did it and then some
I mean that might have been the best
game I've seen him play which by the way
also makes it worse if you're an Eagles
fan that hurts played the best game of
his life and they still lost the game
but to throw for 300 some of the throws
he made to got her I mean the throw he
made to quez Watkins who who didn't
catch it when he was getting blast on
the blitz incredible the rushing so even
though they lost I think the Hertz
performance will resonate in the sense
that we will look at them moving forward
as a contender every year because hertz
can play at that level
and then unfortunately Dan I think I'll
probably remember the anti-climactic
ending I mean we were about to have
maybe the best Super Bowl ever maybe one
of the best finishes maybe overtime and
we had like it was a game-clenching
Ticky tack hold it's just very very very
disappointing but I said that will we
remember the officiating will we
remember the foot the field itself now
obviously you can say well we remember
what Mahomes did in the second half for
Jalen hurts I mean there's a lot of
things you can throw into the blender
here but you know the officiating you
know as much as the commissioner wants
to say was great this year
it wasn't great this year and in the
biggest moment in the biggest game
it came down to you know a questionable
like do you call it then
do you make that call
well first of all no the answer is no
and I want to be very clear about this
that didn't cost the Eagles the game the
chief still would have kicked the field
goal they would have gone up by three
with a minute and 40 left or whatever
what it did was it cost all of us the
opportunity to see how the rest of the
game would have unfolded did the Eagles
go down score a touchdown and win do
they go down and get a fugle we go to
overtime do they not are they it hurts
not able to get it done or they get a
field goal and then Mahomes has 28
seconds and he gets a field goal it just
didn't feel like you know especially
because the chiefs were smart enough to
not score after that it just was like a
game-clenching hole and here's the issue
I have with it and I know your
basketball background Dan and honestly
you're the guy I'll probably listen to
the most when it comes to the NBA stuff
here's the issue and you'll appreciate
this in the first half there was a third
down where Bradbury was covering Juju
the same two guys
and Bradbury gave him a pretty good tug
hold it and then let go yes they didn't
call it yeah and and even Greg Olsen
said oh I don't know about that one that
should have been called as a player you
talk about these things with the coaches
on the sideline and at halftime you play
the rest of the game
based on the way the officials are
calling it this would be like an NBA
game where every time you go to the Lane
you know you get bodied and they don't
call foul don't call foul don't call
foul and then with you know the last
possession of the game they call a hand
check right like yeah Bradbury is
playing the rest of that game based on
the fact that they didn't call him for
being more physical earlier and then you
call a much lesser transgression with
less than two minutes it just doesn't
make sense number one it's not
consistent and number two the timing of
it and the way it makes the players play
it's it's really problematic we're
talking to Ross Tucker uh Westwood one
and CBS Sports I agree with you it's a
great point and all athletes want is
consistency if you're calling that then
I know that now I can adjust my game
it's when you're not calling it you're
not calling it you're not calling it for
59 minutes and then you call it I have a
problem with that and I mentioned
earlier I had a problem no helmet to
helmet call on Devante Smith when he got
hit in the first quarter on the
sidelines knocked him out of bounds
definitely you know helmet to helmet and
they overturned the catch by Devante
Smith where Mike Pereira said the longer
they're waiting the more that it says it
is not conclusive that you overturn that
it just sometimes it all adds up
sometimes it doesn't add up at all I go
back to hertz's Fumble I thought that
they were only up 10 and I said only up
10 and how at halftime and that was
going to come back and hurt them if they
were up no pun intended 27-7 then it's a
different game plan probably for Kansas
City
the Eagles defense did not show up they
looked confused they didn't put pressure
on Mahomes they didn't get a sack on him
I thought the Eagles defense was the
biggest letdown of the night
I would agree and I would add to that
that you know the Eagles needed to be
more dominant dominant up front on both
sides of the ball than they were they
they just weren't you know one of the
things I think is interesting I don't
believe for a second than that the NFL
wanted the footing to be that poor that
was an embarrassment for the league I
don't know how that happens I'm not a
you know I don't know stuff about that
but here's what I do now as an offensive
lineman really offensive player but
especially offensive lineman Dan you
love it when the footing's bad because
the d-linemen can't get off the ball
they can't get a jump off the snap if
the footing's bad and by the way when
the receivers are running their routes
you know the defense has to react to
them so if the NFL wants high scoring
Super Bowls if they want points to be
put up then by all means you know have
turf that guys are slipping like that
because it's almost impossible to get a
pass rush and it's even very hard to
play in the secondary I mean there
really wasn't good coverage hurts threw
for 300 could have been more Patrick
Mahomes I I hardly even remember any
incompletions it felt like he threw the
ball to whoever he wanted wide open
almost every time so I'm not saying the
NFL did it on purpose but part of the
reason why the game was higher scoring
than many of us anticipated was the
footing in my mind
these two teams moving forward Kansas
City revamped their lineup their roster
let Tyree kill go Andy Reed says he's
staying I don't know if Eric the enemy
stays as the offensive coordinator maybe
goes someplace else for that
but he's 20 you know Mahomes is 27.
Kelsey's a little bit older than what
people think but you know you got a
pretty good roster they did a great job
in rebuilding that offensive line I'm
looking at DraftKings they got the
Chiefs is the favorites uh for the Super
Bowl next year what do you make of that
lineup and uh as we ease into the
dynasty word for the Kansas City Chiefs
well look as far as I'm concerned the
Chiefs are the Super Bowl favorites for
the foreseeable future I mean there
Mahomes is the best player by a decent
amount what Andy Reid did in that second
half was masterful I mean masterful went
against Tendencies multiple times I mean
what else do you get by the way bad look
for the Eagles that they scored on the
same exact play to the other side right
like yes I got the first one with
canarius Tony it was a new look Eagles
aren't expecting it okay I got that
but then it was after the pun return it
was third and goal at like the five they
ran the same play to the other side and
they burned them forward again that's
bad like this is pro football this is
not like halftime adjustments this is
hey they just ran this they're gonna
come back to it they get down there
again be looking for it bad look for the
Eagles that that happened but because of
Mahomes and because of not only Andy
Reed but Brett Veach they're GM I mean
the draft he had this year is ridiculous
the amount of contributions they got up
and down the draft board the whole
secondary Pacheco car Loftus the Chiefs
are the favorites moving forward as far
as I'm concerned Philadelphia is going
to be in the mix every year in the NFC
but I don't know that they'll ever have
a roster like this again Dan I mean they
have a lot of free agents they're going
to pay hurts between 40 to 50 million
dollars a year and rightfully so they're
not gonna I mean Gardener Johnson and
Hargrave and Cox and Edwards and Miles
Sanders and samalo they're not going to
be able to keep all these guys so the
Eagles will be in the mix and they'll be
in the mix because roseman's really good
at GM and hertz can play that well but I
do think the chief should be the
favorite
good to talk to you and uh again it was
great seeing you in Arizona thanks for
uh well we'll be in touch we'll bother
you uh during the off season
time you know that Dan 2 th number one
congratulations the granddaughter that's
incredible and number two at the meet
and greet Monday after I left while I
was waiting for my Uber there was like
80 100 people out there and you guys
weren't out there yet so while I was
waiting for my Uber they all they all
wanted me they all want to take self it
was amazing I'm glad I it was genius
moved by me to get out there before you
and the danette's were out there because
I was like the first actual person they
knew that they saw so I got my three and
a half minutes of fame it was incredible
you were the opening act for us and
thank you thank you thank you definitely
definitely that's uh Ross Tucker